[Music]  Wow you're a good friend you gave me the  vitamin C that I couldn't get from my  staff would be good for like three or  four minutes of kindness don't do what I  do and pour it in before you drink a  little bit some I've done that like  twice if burt mustin wasn't it's a  wonderful life i'll eat all of these  nature made vitamin C's but what will  that do us you know get us to not do a  show today all right sweets what the  laughs Sharon laughs hold it  Oh magic bubbles in the hourglass look  at that Ridge you know what people would  be just as happy looking at this sketch  hooking up look at that get in tight  that's just as interesting as anything  we're gonna do  [Applause]  you're a real he-man I know a man we've  wasted people's time over the years just  trying to distract them from this  restless sleep we call life